[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man in this video
i'm going to be breaking down some of
the plot leaks i've heard in regards to
spider-man 3. after we leak the jedi
episode of the mandalorian i promise not
to do full breakdowns on stuff but i did
say that i would talk about certain
things i'd heard now but there's a lot
to discuss and throughout this video
we're going to be talking about the
apparent plot twist in the film the new
villain costumes and other story details
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want anything potentially
ruined then i recommend that you wall
crawl your way out of here make sure you
smash that thumbs up button like you'd
smash aunt may the hot one or the old
one if that's your thing and subscribe
to the channel for videos like this
every day without the way thank you for
clicking this yes sucker now let's get
into the video
okay so i don't think it's a secret at
this point that both toby maguire and
andrew garfield will be playing
alternate versions of peter parker in
the upcoming spider-man movie they've
clearly brought back doc and electro for
a reason and it would be weird to have
them return and not both toby and andrew
i got in a lot of trouble for pooping on
the amazing spider-man 2 in my last
video but let's be real no one was
partying like it's their birthday to
have electro back without there being a
good reason which these peter parkers
are here for i love you by the way jamie
now there's also rumors that willem
dafoe has signed on alongside thomas
hayden church aka the sandman so the
pieces are all falling into place and
paramount even dropped a tweet the other
day teasing at toby and andrew's return
so it's pretty safe to say that it's
definitely happening and it's going to
make spider-man 3 one of the biggest
movies of all time now before we get
into the big plot twist in the film we
have to discuss how one division
spider-man 3 and doctor strange are all
connected in some way after the disney
investor day event it was said that
these three would sort of be a trilogy
that played into each other much in the
same way that civil war tied in with
black panther and spider-man homecoming
sam raimi is directing doctor strange
too and i'm sure you're well aware that
he was behind the original spider-man
trilogy but just in case you aren't yeah
he basically created the universe and
was a huge get for marvel studios if you
checked out mine in den of the nerds big
spoiler stream at the weekend then
you'll know that josh brought up that
raymie was pivotal in getting alfred
molina to return and that he's been a
key partner negotiations to get people
back with raymie directing doctor
strange too and this tying into
spider-man 3 it does add way to these
three properties being linked and this
sort of trilogy will center highly
around alternate dimensions and
realities now according to what i've
heard one division will center around
scarlet witch creating a pocket
dimension in which she can live out her
dream life with vision the character
grew up watching old reruns of us
sitcoms and viewed this as the ideal way
to be so this is why the show carries
this sort of weird aesthetic the plot
leaks say that things go to hell in this
dimension and it causes issues across
the multiverse now whilst this is going
on peter is also on the run after the
events are far from home and from what
i've heard he actually goes to strange
for help the pair of course met in
infinity war and strange obviously knows
that he would never murder someone just
to command a drone fleet because he
knows him beyond just using their made
up names he sees him as a good kid and
decides that he will do what he can to
clear his name thus strange casts a
spell to make the entire world forget
that peter parker is spider-man
if you're a fan of marvel comics then
you'll know that this plot point
appeared in one moment in time and it
saw the sorcerer erasing the knowledge
from everyone's memory so that peter's
life could return to some form of
normality this caused issues down the
line and apparently this plot motif will
be carried across to the film if you
cast your mind back to doctor strange
you'll remember that mordo warned him
about the dangers of dabbling in magic
when first using the time stone the
character was furious that strange was
meddling with things he didn't
understand and that in doing so he could
create time loops alternate realities
and so on it was also revealed that the
ancient one had been pulling from the
dark dimension in order to prolong her
life and has very much been this idea
already planted that with magic often
comes at cost this is the same case for
the movie and in doing so strange will
cause a tear in the fabric of reality
that basically opens up the entire
multiverse from what i've heard that's
strange's role in the movie and we
already know that he's been officially
confirmed as appearing in the film it
also sets up the events for his own solo
sequel in the multiverse of madness and
the big focus for the next phase which
will be alternate dimensions the first
three phases of the mcu pretty much all
led to end game which is when the
avengers opened up several alternate
realities and we saw further notes to
the multiverse in far from home with the
arrival of mysterio though he wasn't
actually from an alternate dimension it
actually set up several things in place
which hint towards the next phase
whereas the first three phases centered
around the prime timeline versions of
the character the future phases will
focus on alternate ones so that's going
to be a big direction for things going
forward and this aesthetic will of
course appear in the alternate version
of vision in one division loki which
will have several versions of the god of
mischief spider-man 3 which yeah gonna
have everyone in it and doctor strange 2
which will also contain alternate
versions of the character according to
my source marvel are trying to bring
across established versions of
characters from different properties and
we may even be seeing some of the x-men
down the line that we already know from
the fox films i'll let you know more
when i find out but that's just what
i've heard in the meantime and that kind
of takes us to the villains of
spider-man 3 and i have to make it clear
that the ones appearing in the movie
will not be the versions that we've
already seen before dark ark of course
died as did electro and thus these will
be different versions of the character
and because of that they'll come with
alternate looks jamie foxx already
teased in a now deleted instagram post
the electro will not be blue and this
will follow suit with them the suits of
the different characters
pretty crap pun now from what i've heard
they're actually trying to create a
green goblin look that will resemble the
comic book version if you cast your mind
back to the behind the scenes stuff on
the first spider-man movie you may
remember that the original green goblin
costume looked a lot more in line with
the source material and marvel are
trying to go that route with the foe's
appearance in the film so in regards to
the villains we will be getting their
quote-unquote classic costumes and this
will allow versions of them to exist in
the mcu without saying that the previous
films they've stored in don't count
anymore now going forward what i've
heard is that sony marvel studios have
actually agreed that when this is all
over the former will be able to use
spider-man in their own properties which
will be unconnected from the mcu by that
i mean they can have a version of andrew
garfield off doing his own thing in a
separate continuity
whilst tom holland operates in the main
timeline this is why in the mobius
trailer we saw a poster of the raimi
spider-man with murderer written over it
and though they'll all be disconnected
if they want to bring them back together
they can through the multiverse now
that's all the rumors and plot leaks
have heard and hopefully we get some
more info over the next coming weeks
which clear everything up spider-man 3
is gonna be peter parker's endgame level
event and the plan is to have this show
that fans won't have to wait another 10
years before we get films of that size
i would of course love to hear your
thoughts on it and don't forget that on
the 30th of december we're giving away
three copies of the lord of the rings 4k
boxset to our subscribers all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the leaks
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of all the other rumors we've
heard which are going to be linked at
the end we discussed the snyder cut
spider-man 3 and a lot more so it's
definitely worth checking out if you if
you're bored at home with nothing to do
anyway with that other way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time take care
peace